es una elección estatal con
implicaciones nacionales es por ello que
joe biden estaba en long beach haciendo
campaña con gavin newsom quien intenta
mantener su asiento de gobernador de
california las encuestas predicen que
newsom no será destituido pero el
presidente insta a los demócratas a no
tomar ningún riesgo y carbono rico
tienen que votar no en la consulta
mantengan a gavin como gobernador el
resto de eeuu cuenta con ustedes y
también yo lo hago un resentimiento
creciente por el manejo de la pandemia
además de la crisis por los incendios
forestales y diversos escándalos sobre
newsom son algunas de las razones por
las cuales su trabajo está en juego él
insiste en que una victoria republicana
suprimiría los valores progresistas del
estado
no puede ser que el tropismo no tiene
lugar aquí y el campismo será derrotado
en todo eeuu
el lunes los primeros votantes
depositaron sus papeletas
no quiero que ocurra esta toma
republicana en california no me gustan
algunos candidatos republicanos soy un
pequeño negociante durante el último año
pero no esencial y por ello no pude
trabajar mientras que en otros estados
habría podido operar así que estaba
emocionado por la destitución y voté por
destituir a new song en las papeletas
hay dos preguntas debería gavin newson
ser destituido y si sí quien debería
reemplazarlo si una simple mayoría vota
a favor del reemplazo entonces quien sea
que obtenga el mayor número de votos en
la segunda pregunta tomaría su lugar es
relativamente fácil organizar un
referendo de destitución en california
los solicitantes solamente deben reunir
firmas del 12% del número de personas
que votaron en la última elección que en
este caso fue particularmente bajo en
2003 el estado anuló una elección cuando
el demócrata gray davis fue reemplazado
por el republicano arnold schwarzenegger